Danny let it out I want you to hit me
trust me come on it's okay
oh okay
oh
a real tough guy come on Annie hit me
[Laughter]
oh
that was better so sorry oh
that's Marcia Gay Harden in First Wives
Club she's an Oscar and Tony
award-winning actor and now she's
starring in the new CBS legal drama so
help me Todd Hardin plays Margaret
Wright who hires her son Todd as the
in-house investigator for her law firm
in hopes of repairing their damaged
relationship I know easier said than
done they work together solving cases
while hashing out their mother's son
drama take a look
can you tell me Todd why would someone
screw up their entire life by doing
something illegal
but I bounce back with your help right
and look at me now a productive member
of society putting on my pants and going
to work every day by putting on your
pants is the bar then I have failed as a
mother no do not come in here this door
is closed to you
I need to go waste some more of my
billable hours
public defender well thank you greedy
lady lawyer for gaining to help my
peasant friend with his expensive legal
woes I don't want to hear it you know
what I'm going to go over to that pawn
shop and figure out who really did this
time and mine down the toilet maybe
Brian has a look-alike or a car alike or
maybe the pawn shop owner Rob himself oh
my God you're right maybe he did it
could be insurance fraud I know fraud
yes you do
Marcia Gay Harden joins us right now how
are you doing I'm doing great good
morning good morning so this show it
Blends comedy and drama very well what
Drew you to it that it's a legal show so
you get a case of the week but that it
is Comic as well I love physical comedy
I love being in comedies like nothing
else and Skyler and I have this really
bantering relationship and they wrote
this fantastic mother-son banter of
course so I was like that's kind of what
I want to do for the next couple of
years am I saying that I'm saying that
of course so are the you have great
chemistry the writing is strong but it
was such that with that Dynamic being so
essential to the show do you guys
improvise as he throw lines in do you
throw lines in he's a master at throwing
lines in and I throw physical things in
he's really good at like little comments
at the end and then and and they make
they make it better it's like little
buttons and then I'll say what about if
my character like falls off her chair on
this moment like okay try it try it but
what does it mean to you I think it's so
nice that Skyler has said publicly that
he and his real mom sort of freak out
that you're playing the on-camera mob
listen you're an Oscar winner you're a
Tony winner so they go it's Marcia
you're a legend in this business you're
a legendary you're a little diva turn I
go like I do oh really yeah you're
enjoying it with me darling my voice
goes down you know like Skyler come to
set please
I love that
uh production company behind the show is
Dr Phil's production company yeah so I
don't know a lot about TV but I know if
you run the production company you can
do whatever you want you can show up or
not yes he shows up first of all he
comes he has come to set before and he
did this whole analysis of the
mother-son relationship and he's like
well I'd say that's dysfunctional your
mother's a little controlling isn't she
was like we're literally getting therapy
on set and he did he's done like a funny
little swoop of it as well where he
interviewed both of us in character but
he's analyzing us all the time which I
think is is exciting here for this like
who doesn't have mother-son mother child
issues like they're so normal and he's
kind of putting his Dr Phil spin on it I
know it's on the script notes on the
self uh that can be important speaking
of a therapy inducing moment I I would
have to imagine as my kids get older uh
when they go off to college right the
nest empties out your son recently uh
made that transition how you feeling my
I'm a little it gets clean is out a
little bit sad I took my son to Scotland
and um I had four different countrymots
he left a country what does that say
what's Dr Phil going to say about that
he needed to get away from here
quiet Dr Phil but he I went over there
and I had so little time to go like I
was racing to get over there I was
expecting my son at last minute to say
mom you don't need to come it's okay I
know you're busy you're on the show
nothing like that he was like uh-huh
when are you going to be here because
you're going to help me buy the sheets
and help do my bed and then you're going
to get in that car and the cab to the
airport and you're gonna cry as you look
out the window and everything was true
they still need us I think that never
gets old I love what you wrote in the
post that we showed it says uh 18 years
listening to him seeing hum chatter sing
hum chatter yes and it's quiet now it's
quiet the noise makers when they're in
the house you might make me cry now it
is quiet it's too quiet he's a beautiful
singer we're always listening to him in
the kitchen making noise and now it's a
little quiet the house takes a turn but
you know I always say you give them the
foundation and you give them their wings
yes strap them on and let it soar but it
is let them soar but it is there is a
dynamic shift in the house I say give
them the foundation and then you can
decorate the house yourself
but have the roots but what doesn't
change is your talent Marcia Gay Harden
Oscar win a Tony winner you run
uncoupled with uh Neil Patrick Harris
yes you said you described that
character as a grand Huffy mess you like
playing grand huffy and you're on the
morning show you like playing yes I do
yeah I really do there's nothing more
fun than to play somebody with a bunch
of flaws and when you meet someone who's
Huffy there's nothing more fun than them
coming off of their little pedestal you
know and they're they're hubris as they
do that's quite fun Marcia listen I am a
ham for the camera but I have nothing on
you oh you have an outfit on me is what
you have well I mean we're coming yeah
you are beautiful I I I got to ask you
about this Clint Eastwood story that as
I understand it when you first met him
you were such a big fan that you bit a
hole in your tongue this is a true story
that this is a true story I fangirled so
hard over him when I met him because I
grew up watching Rawhide and I fell in
love with him when I was young and how
old were you at the time 17. no that you
bit a hole in your tongue no I was you
were a grown woman and my voice went to
something screechy and my I was saying
things I didn't I lurched at him I
kissed him I was like excited and then I
bit a hole in my tongue and I had to go
outside of the trailer to say excuse me
Mr Eastwood I bet the whole of my song I
just did Ice and I can do my job
perfectly and I had to put ice on my
tongue to do my job oh Betty remembers
you're mortified oh Marcia Gay Harden
thank you so much we appreciate you
thank you you can watch so help me Todd
Thursdays at nine eight Central on CBS
and on Paramount plus and Marcia will be
guest tonight on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert we can't wait for that
yeah that'll be fun we will be right
back
tonight